Now in the last few
minutes, the US
Secretary of Defense
said the downing
of a US spy drone
in international airspace
yesterday was part of a pattern of,
quote, aggressive,
risky and unsafe actions by Russia.
Lloyd Austin's comments
come one day
after the Pentagon
accused a Russian fighter
jet of hitting
an American spy drones propeller,
forcing it
to crash into international waters.
But Russia's ambassador to Washington
is insisting
the incident didn't happen
and is warning
the US not to enter
the airspace as the war rages in Ukraine.
This drone can carry a few booms.
You'll see that.
What will be the issue
of the United States?
If you'll see such a Russian drone,
very close, for example, to San Francisco
or New York?
What will the reaction
of the United States? For me, it's clear
and some Abdulaziz joins us now
on this summer.
Perhaps no surprise
that there's a difference of opinion over
what happened here
given the broader backdrop.
What do we know?
Firstly, about what happened?
What more happened?
What about the data on the drone
and the perhaps the communications
behind the scenes here to avoid
further escalation?
Absolutely.
Two very different narratives
coming from Moscow in D.C.
The United States says
that Russia intentionally hit
this drone, struck this drone
it says that Russian jets
were in the vicinity of it,
essentially harassing
it between
reading between the lines for 30
to 40 minutes,
dumping fuel on that drone
before that
Russian fighter jet
went behind
that drone and clipped its propeller.
The drone
then that reaper drone
being forced to crash to land
into not land rather crash
into the Black Sea a total loss U.S.
officials say.
But Moscow says this is simply not true.
They deny that there was
any physical contact
between one of their fighter jets.
And if you ask me, drone Russia says
in fact, that it
detected an intruder over
the Black Sea waters.
It scrambled its fighter jets
that that drone, the U.S.
Army drone, did not have its transponders
on which Russia says is a violation
of international standards and norms.
In fact,
Russia says
it had warned
that it was operating in the air,
that it was carrying out
its special military operations
in that Black Sea area and had warned
about that action
and in fact, blames the United States.
Pointing fingers at the US,
says it's America
that was behaving recklessly, dangerously
in the Black Sea.
One Kremlin spokesman
saying that relationships
between Russia
and the United States are deplorable
now that they're at an all time low.
Now, one positive sign
is that both sides seem to agree
that this should not escalate
any further.
Russia's ambassador to D.C.
to the United States was summoned.
There was about a 30 minute meeting there
in the State Department.
He called it constructive.
So for now, it seems that
neither party wants to see this escalate.
But all eyes on the Black Sea
as to whether or not
the Americans can somehow.
And it's impossible to imagine
that this could take place,
could somehow
get the remnants
of that drone from the Black Sea.
But important to note, of course,
Russia very much operates
in that flashpoint area of the Black Sea.
Some.
Abdulaziz, thank you for joining us.
Colin Edwards at the State Department.
Ivan Watson is in eastern Ukraine.
And you're there monitoring
not just what's going on the ground,
but the response on this incident
from the Kremlin. What's been said
Well, we've
seen the first official response
from the Ukrainian government
to this incident
in the Black Sea,
and not much of a surprise
given how
closely allied Kiev and Washington are.
The head of the National Security
and Defense
Council has called Russia's alleged
downing of this American Air Force drone
a provocation
and said that this indicates
Putin's readiness
to expand the conflict zone
with the involvement of other parties.
So we're standing very much
behind the U.S. on this.
Again, not much of a surprise.
The Russians have claimed
that no weapons
were used to force down this U.S.
Air Force Reaper
and that there was no conflict tact
between the Russian fighter jets
and the drone itself,
which is something
that the Pentagon is disputing.
Now, I want to turn
your attention, Becky,
to another incident
that took place
just to show you
how frequent
these types of aerial intercepts are.
This is over Estonia where
a British and German warplane
were scrambled to intercept
and then escort a Russian military plane
over Estonia after the.
The Royal Air Force says that
the Russian
plane did not respond
to air traffic control.
This is apparently a Russian
refueling plane
that was flying
between the Russian enclave
of Kaliningrad and St Petersburg.
There were no collisions here.
This is a standard practice
that we see practiced around the world.
But something went very wrong
in the Black Sea
and had raised tensions there Becky.
Well, Ivan, thank you.
Let's get to the State Department then.
What do we understand happened?
Well, listen, what U.S.
officials are saying
is that, first of all,
there were
two Russian aircraft
that poured fuel onto this drone,
and then
that there was
one of the Russian aircrafts aircraft
who actually intercepted the U.S. drone.
And that's what led to it going down.
So they're being pretty clear
in saying
that this was a very risky
and very aggressive action by Russia.
Now, one
interesting thing
that we learned this morning
from John Kirby
from the National Security Council
at the White House
is that
there is some footage of this incident
actually occurring.
The Pentagon has that footage.
We're waiting to see
if the Biden administration
decides to make that footage public,
because that could provide
a very clear accounting
potentially of what actually went down.
And what we also heard from Kirby
this morning
was that what the US has done is
take steps
to make sure
that any of the information that are on
that drone is protected.
They can obviously do that remotely
because it's a drone
that's remotely operated.
But what he also said
is that they're not sure
if they're actually going to be able
to recover this drone
because it's just so far
in the depths of the Black Sea right now.
So that is a point for us to also watch.
We heard from the secretary of defense
this morning, Lloyd Austin,
who talked about the incident
and how it's not going to prevent
the U.S.
from flying these drones
in international airspace is going forth.
Listen to what he said.
I know
that everyone here has heard that
Russian aircraft, again
engaged in dangerous,
reckless and unprofessional practices
on Tuesday
in international airspace
over the Black Sea.
Two Russian jets dumped fuel
on an unmanned U.S.
MQ nine aircraft
conducting routine operations
in international airspace.
And one Russian jet intercepted and hit
our MQ nine aircraft
resulting in a crash.
This hazardous episode
is a part of a pattern
of aggressive
and risky and unsafe actions
by Russian pilots
in international airspace.
So make no mistake,
the United States will continue to fly
and to operate
wherever international law allows.
And it is incumbent upon Russia
to operate its military aircraft
in a safe and professional manner.
Now, what we've also heard from U.S.
officials
is that incidents
like this increase
the risk of miscount dilation.
And the concern here is that
there could be more confrontation
between the US and Russia.
Beyond this, of course, the Ukraine war.
But between the two nations directly
and that is the concern here.
What we're waiting to see
is the full extent of the U.S. response.
Obviously, we have seen them condemning
what happened.
Condemning Russia's aggression.
But we're waiting to see
if there's more to come
from the Biden administration.
And on the part of the Kremlin,
the spokesperson is saying,
and I quote, The US and Russia
relations are in a, quote,
deplorable state
and at their lowest point.
Another quote, adding that
Russian President
Vladimir Putin
was briefed on the incident.
Always a pleasure.
Thank you very much indeed.